نحن ممتنون لجهودكم ونريد ان نكرمكم ونقول
لكم شكرا هذه رساله مهرجان فريد من نوعه
في احدى بلدات المكسيك الاحتفاء هنا ليس
باحد رواد البلده فالمهرجان مخصص فقط
لتكريم الحمير
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
هنا في بلده اوتومبا المكسيكيه مئات الاسر
تخرج في مهرجان الحمار السنوي الذي يتزامن
مع احتفالات عيد العمال هذه البلده قررت
الاحتفاء بالحمير امتلانا منهم لتحملها
عبء الاعمال الشاقه ودورها الاساسيه في
الانشطه البلده لا سيما نقل وتوزيع السلع
المحليه وحيث وزراعه الاراضي
[موسيقى]
مناسم الاحتفالات تبدا بكرنفان الحمير حيث
يتم الباس هذه الحيوانات ازياء مختلفه
وملونه فهذا الحمار ارتدى ملابس مهرج مرح
ببالونات علقت على عربه يجرها وهذا الحمار
الذي يحول الهرب البسه صاحبه ملابس ماريو
وهنا حمار زيه يعود للعصر الفرعوني
[موسيقى]
يلا سبيرسولا اللغات
المهرجان يشهد كذلك سباقات ومباريات
لرياضه البولو لكن على صهوات الحمير وليس
الخيول كما هو متعارف عليه الجماهير وقفت
في ساحه المهرجان لتشجيع المتسابقين
اكيد
فكره الاحتفاء بالحمير تعود الى القرن
السادس عشر حيث قرر سكان البلدان جعل
الاول من مايو يوما مخصصا لتكريم هذا
الحيوان
المهرجان لقي شهره محليه وعالميه الكثير
من السكان المحليين والسياح يتوجهون الى
هذه البلده الصغيره لمتابعه احتفالات
المهرجان الذي ينتهي بفعاليه مميزه وهي
اختيار ملكه جمال الحمير